happy halloween everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
all right good morning everybody today
we are gonna go to a drive-in halloween
uh
what are we doing today your wife bought
the tickets yeah i don't even know what
we're doing today but it's a halloween
event
just drive-in thing so it's going to be
socially distanced and i brought my car
like i said in the last vlog
i rented this kia telluride to test
drive for one because i'm in the market
for a new car
and we were moving stuff so needed the
space to move stuff
and might as well test the uh the
comfort levels of this car we're gonna
max out all seven seats here today
with two car seats so i think this is
the ultimate test drive in my opinion
and now
ant is gonna take it for a spin i just
want to see what is what this ride is
like it's so
this is such a nice car it is it is it's
a it's key it's a kia yeah but even the
kia logo is so nice it's so shiny
it does feel like a smaller sized car or
like a sedan because the steering wheel
is nice and small
it is a little sporty there's comfort
mode sport mode
smart i can't feel the difference
between comfort eco and smart but
between sport and comfort you can
definitely feel like the torque and all
that
when you rent a car you use sport all
the time but then when you buy it
you're with some comforter i'm trying to
save my engine i'm trying to save the
car itself and the gas
all right let's see oh it's nice it's
light yeah
oh oh and it takes off yeah it's got a
little torque to it
all right so i guess i'm going to sell
my car
and get this we're going to twins
this drives way better than my car oh
does it it's smaller oh it's true you
just made that u-turn like it was
nothing
it feels like i'm driving with a
family sedan it does i don't know what
it's really about
we're spying on it or something like
that i don't know but it sounds pretty
fun and we're all gonna go on one car
and it's crazy because we have seven of
us
look at this ride i'm spying on you what
are you spying at
i'm just watching how you vlog i guess
you should have told me to suck in my
dad's butt
should i sell my car and get this one
too yes
i should yes so we could be twins in i
might pull the trigger
it depends on the size of this car
because i do like how mine is very big
and i fit a lot of stuff in there
because i do construction sometimes true
and i like getting a lot of wood in the
back your car looks a little smaller
true i don't know from so you're trying
to measure from here
to the to the front front row that's
what i want to do
[Music]
i got my measuring tape and
is some dad talk right there like only a
dad talks about things like that
i'm gonna do come some some construction
i gotta measure the back of my car the
car seats and
that a little bit
all right it's like 15 feet you know
i've been easier
if i just if we google this yes
you could just a toyota 4runner versus a
telluride and would have done it this is
more fun
if anything it looks like your car is
longer well there's a set
seven seater there's an extra rope but i
mean these cars you're you're
you're come to the seven seater too
though it does but your car is actually
longer
by like half a foot yes i win i might
have lost the the knife battle
but i won the car battle all right what
are we about to do
we're gonna go to hauntoween
which is this event where we drive
through and we get to
experience trick-or-treating inside of
our cars everyone has their mess
yes yes yeah oh that's a great question
well people come up to our
windows and like no fairy six feet away
i read that too
oh that's all right social distance
we're not there
i'm yet so excited so we got leia here
you can't see what she's wearing but she
has a little orange
pumpkin outfit it's so cute it was so
adorable because while we were waiting
for everyone to get ready i was playing
with leia for like a solid
half an hour and she kept getting all
her fake food and then like feeding it
to the pumpkin she's like the baby gets
to eat the baby we were having a grand
old time huh girlfriend
she's like whatever let me just maybe
stay with you
i was just writing my hoverboard around
here i know i saw but it's okay
we were having some girl time and then
enzo here just woke up from a nap
little pikachu cutie pie and then what
are you aunt
a responsible father that's what you
dressed up as yep
i'm getting kicked by this guy i know
and then and then look at you
the way you're seated it's just like
you're so squished in there i'm snugged
but it feels good i'm in between the
kids you know we have a long drive right
yep i know it's like a whole hour before
we get there
yeah yeah i didn't know the guys were
having car talk for 30 minutes
i know you guys were really talking
about cars for 30 minutes yeah i left
you hanging i was like measuring the car
and everything
so which one's bigger your car's bigger
this one yeah really it's crazy
oh it snaps that's pretty cool it's
really um
really compact too true i tested it
already
yeah i saw him driving i heard her
playing with leia in the living room
when i was feeding enzo and i was like
they probably left her and she's just
watching
she was like where's daddy i was like
it's okay he's coming back
no and then also side note how cute is
it that christina and i are matching
we totally didn't plan and we didn't
find that either
we're just that adorable great minds
think alike just kidding this is such a
cute outfit though i like it yeah
nice work we're orange for halloween
this is our costume for now i actually
didn't realize i was like oh
yeah we should have tried dressing up or
something
totally forgot to do that but it's okay
okay so isaac is in the process of
trying to tell the car
where we're trying to go but he's
freaking out
so he's he wasn't able to get any word
out it was pretty funny
sorry i didn't you got this isaac
he got it no pressure no pressure
you could do it i still didn't
understand we're gonna skip our exit
is it six thousand one hundred no just
say the the numbers
six thousand i still can't no baby you
don't have to say
thousand just say the numbers your
window is minimize cabin noise
then press the speak button six
one zero zero taponga
canyon boulevard los angeles california
topanga hopefully that worked
there we go oh you did it
good job but it was so cute because in
the beginning he was like
i'm freaking out man i'm freaking out i
don't know what to say what do i say
six thousand six thousand one hundred
everyone's listening to me
i think we should reward him by letting
him drive now oh
you're trying to put your family at risk
like that oh
man this looks so pretty i like it this
is a nice car so you guys are talking
about
uh maybe possibly reconsidering your
forerunner and getting
getting this one this is a really nice
car yeah right i like it it's smooth
it feels great i mean it looks nice
and it's really comfortable too because
there's like rims on this car right yeah
it's so smooth when you're in his car
it's like dude
oh really yeah you're just like bouncing
me better shots
no it's it's the tires are really big uh
you know
you're trying to overcompensate for
something yeah never mind
what what just happened you just agreed
that you're overcompensating for
something else
i think you were making that joke aunt
no i wasn't even trying to get there
oh i don't know what happened that's not
funny
you're laughing he's like just laughed
she's not like now i know what's going
on i'm 12.
i'm 12 now i know on oh no and then and
then five more years i'm 18
yeah out of the house yep rub it in my
face why don't you
i'm excited yeah we just got here
we're in the line about to enter we have
our
qr code ready we got our masks ready
oh do you have your bucket for for candy
i said trick or treat smell my feet
give me something great
too yeah oh sick we all should have had
buckets
i know right where's your bucket
i'll just fill it up until it's fill and
dunk it on myself oh look at that
yeah i got it i got it i'm excited me
too
this looks so cool why am i so excited
this is
what quarantine has done to us man we're
just like so excited to drive
through something
how about taco bell after this and all
right
taco bell guys you can have this one
open
oh yeah oh nice oh
how cool yeah you ready like yeah this
is fun
oh so fun
[Music]
i feel like we're at disneyland or
something but we're in line in a car
waiting in line
[Music]
what do you think isaac he's pretty cool
he said he said that like he's an older
kid
a big kid he's like yeah that's pretty
cool yeah yeah
[Music]
i can take it okay she wants it she
wants it she knows what she wants
oh we have a broken stem oh no another
one okay
oh yeah perfect
thank you so much
this thing is massive it's bigger than
you i know come on
[Applause]
yeah thank you that was awesome
oh no once she sees a g-h-o-s-t
oh oh no yeah i wonder how she knows
[Music]
oh you don't want a broken stem okay and
then he saw the biggest and long
hard one
[Music]
this is how all the theme park should
open reopen back up somehow
i know how cars come in and just wash
stuff
this would have been so much better
during night time but this is the latest
showing that they had for this day
oh really still cool though yeah because
i was like there's another
terrier right over there the kia taylor
rides and it's like you're gonna wave
and i'm like no you gotta do the nod
tell your right dog yeah does that tell
you right connection you know that's
like the second
cholo i've seen driver tell you right
though
i've only seen three trolls huh what
makes a macholo
oh cause he's bald and he's got uh laker
stuff on
that constitutes the tolo guys there you
go that's true
thomas loves the lakers though like
undeniably like they just love them
duh who doesn't like lakers and the
dodgers they like their l.a teams that's
true
yeah and raiders and the dallas cowboys
for some reason
that's weird
[Music]
this reminds me of animal crossing with
all the different houses oh that's my
villager
there's another villager there's another
villager
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm here to tell you that we're always
here nice greeting people
40 hours a day eight days a week that's
right
then wake him up happy halloween
[Music]
[Music]
okay
this guy has been dancing the whole time
uh we've been watching far away
let's see if we can get on dance even
[Applause]
more
i should have given him some candy oh
yeah
some tips candy tips happy halloween
we finally did something festive during
this very
long spring break the longest spring
break of our lives
true so awesome thank you guys for
inviting us
this is fun thank you thanks for joining
us
did you have fun she's licking all the
candy and smiling
yeah she's like i got candy that's all i
care about we didn't get any skittles
what what is this holidays
is that your favorite candy yeah what's
going on
yeah oh what's that why would you want
skittles when you have kids
pencils it says witches are real is that
what that says
yeah trick-or-treat oh you got one
trick or treat i don't know
when yeah you have to say trick-or-treat
and everyone want a candy
was that that was a sign they say
[Applause]
she got you by the tail she's just like
this i know
it works same with auntie
all you had to do was go and that was
trick or treat man this is a massive
pumpkin i can't get over how huge this
pumpkin is
[Music]
all right we got our shake shack and
we're at a parking lot and about to
enjoy i have an invisible gopro
you like this new gopro yeah yeah it's
really cool
yeah you have an invisible uh case oh
yeah i do
or about to eat a shake shack and enjoy
a nice delicious meal
look it's pikachu
[Music]
you